good morning good morning everyone hello
believe nation it's great to be here
again it's Friday welcome to gratitude
journal live stream number 30 wasn't
always a big fan of Friday's cuz the end
of the work week for a lot of people
start to get stuff down the weekend but
Jay Reise comes over on Fridays so every
day is extra special here because we
love our fridays um we need more happy
entrepreneurs guys we need half the
entrepreneurs go out there and make a
big difference in this world and it's
going to come from you being grateful
for what you do already have in your
life and so we do this gratitude journal
live stream every weekday 90 and Eastern
you could join me in the process it's
something that's I found really helpful
in my life and my team has as well and
so I thought hey let's bring it to
believe nations believe nation to I
share three things I'm grateful for you
share three things you're grateful for
you given the live chat or the comments
afterwards and it's important that you
do it daily it's important that you
actually feel it just ask yourself why
with each one why it's so important to
you and do that consistently you'll
start to feel you'll feel a lot better
to be a lot happier and I think that's
important so I'm going to start off
three things I'm grateful for myself
with that with Nina there she is um Nina
Nina takes care of a lot of things in
our lives which is highly appreciated we
have a salsa party y comes up as uber we
have a salsa Halloween party coming up
for trial dance salsa and and she took
care of getting our costumes figuring
out what we're going to be you know
about stuff and last night I was trying
on my costume and I'm pretty jazzed by
the costume I'm pretty excited by I was
gonna wear part of it a little sneak
peek for you guys today was in a web
part of it but some of the people from
from TDs watch this stream and so it's
supposed to be a surprise what we are so
we'll just maybe maybe on Halloween what
days Hollywood thinks the Friday pretty
sure it's a friday maybe it's not movies
a Thursday no it's a tuesday anyways so
it's a weekday may be for Halloween I
like I'll come in full costume you guys
to see what it is anyway but you don't
need it takes care of a lot of stuff for
us and that is amazing and it lets lets
me do what I do as well that's number 1
number 2 i'm grateful for working sinks
the sink in our condo was backed up and
Nina got some of that Drano or whatever
it's called I don't know if it's working
but I go to the kitchen and there's like
saran wrap that's her in a plastic wrap
the legs would like thicker scram it
what's the thicker strap black wax paper
that's sort of this watch paper across
the sink not allowed to use the sink and
it's funny how you know you don't
realize how important something is like
a sink until until you can't use it
which is also the point of these
gratitude streams a lot of the things
that you guys saying these gratitude
streams I take for granted to every day
and it's awesome to see it come up so
it's on my radar too so I'm grateful for
working sinks and the products and
people that fix them like Drano or
repair men and women because I can and
number 3 i'm grateful for taking chances
i'm working on a little ninja project
that that may not be so little soon
because i use YouTube differently than
how a lot of people use YouTube and I'm
looking at doing a change I'm still on
YouTube don't don't freak out it's gonna
be a lot of the same stuff but i'm doing
i'm looking at a change that i haven't
seen anybody else do so i will see I'm
talking to my i'm talking to youtube
today later on today and i'm talking to
some other people to get their advice
next week and I'm excited I'm excited
I'm excited that I the willingness to
take chances
I hope that you guys are taking chances
in your businesses to all right we got
six minutes left let's do some live
appreciation and gratitude shoutouts
what we got zaino kicking us off welcome
believe nation what do you get from for
today thank you say no it's always
interesting who starts it off it's
between J reyez a no and livable who
lose I don't I don't get to do it
anymore you guys are stealing the
Thunder I love it he says I won't be
here for the live streams because I'm
I'm gonna crush my dad at snooker but I
wish you all a wonderful day I write
happy crushing its liquor history things
physical house health I lenses and warm
water I love it Melissa hello believe
people happy face best you pro good
morning everyone it's a beautiful
morning here in Kingston Jamaica I love
it it is a crazy cloudy rainy day here
in Toronto but we're feeling the Sun
that you're bringing into the chat klb
and I'm good before one reaching 114
shares from I go fund me page
congratulations to having clean clothes
to wear super important and three black
jaguar-white lying foundation because
they displayed man's love for animal and
vice versa never heard of the black
jaguar-white line foundation but thank
you for bringing that up rescue pro we
are grateful to have made it in we have
made it in early this morning grateful
for Twitter and for reaching 1800
followers I love it congrats river for
the support from friends and colleagues
and most of all for life I love it
that's a great attitude coming from
Kingston Jamaica Peggy hey hey Peggy Jer
eyes thankful for warm welcoming
invitations thanks thankful for a
talented caring supportive teammates
thankful for every moment of joy ease
and reliefs life provides I love that
Jay brought me some new nettle tea as
well so I'm a different brand and may be
trying that later on today here
anonymous world changer hi Evan welcome
anonymous Sarah good morning good
morning Melissa I'm grateful today for
spring valley
fish oil and multivitamins to I'm get
booth and grateful for being able to
reach our goal to dream trip Orlando and
go fund me page Zoe Amell hello Evan
welcome Zoya what else what else Donna
people for life family friends and
community awesome Evan 11 Donna hola Jay
riser eyes getting some love in the chat
sweat hello everyone hope you're having
a good start to the day thank you for
that melissa is also grateful for
youtube channel that lets her learn a
lot of success for free i agree i love
you too dice aw gee sod gaming hope I
got that ok heaven I'm a science student
if I'm not get enough motivation to
study please inspire me join us in three
minutes on the league of legends live
chat and we'll go over any business
question probably why I'm seeing Jay
Rise every day you don't your CJ rise
every day you see jrez everywhere whoa
boss since the nineties whoo all right
back at you Adrian good morning happy 30
days that's two is 30 days it's that's a
month celebration Jen Jen from you so
much you want me to celebrate we should
have like the little cupcake or
something here I got nothing celebration
nettle tea the junior is brought today
I'm excited for that nyasha I'm grateful
for life family and friends the lookout
for me even when I am not there for them
cool what else Sarah I'm grateful with
this gratitude journal we prefer this
beautiful rainy day and grateful for my
clients I love that Deanna's going salsa
dancing tonight me too I'll love channel
some Diana while dancing crystal I'm
grateful for my health that I'm healthy
enough to pursue my purpose good for my
husband that I have a partner too I love
that crystal saini see any hope you're
not said okay grateful for my gratitude
jars and how they spread the message to
always be thankful what's a gratitude
jar
it's not like you put something in there
like you put nuts in a jar so thankful
and then let you think about thankful
when you eat the net it's interesting
anyway look at look that up um grateful
for another beautiful day on earth I
love that grateful for this positive
community good Highlander I'm grateful
for my loved ones energy minute if my
life I group of my loved ones energy
minute if my life and today I'm grateful
for my body it's perfect in every way
and then I got cut off all right we'll
give me two and three let's see what you
got crystal bit before my health my
husband and my children Prabhu people
for turning up at the right time wise
and otherwise hidden it implies it I'm
grateful for a peaceful life and sweat
grateful for you people with whom I
share good times every day love it guys
nine ten we're going to go off the
twitch play a game of League of Legends
and answer some business questions this
is the last time I see today it's Friday
go and crush it one more day to close
the week a little bit of work on the
weekend right don't your commission
that's it guys thank you for joining me
every day thank you for 30 days of
Awesomeness will keep this thing going
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is I'll see you soon